[Music]
all right hello everyone I'm Cassie I
work at Jimdo as a developer and today
we're going to talk about Houdini as I
realized yesterday especially is that a
lot of people don't actually know what
Houdini is and so first thing we want to
find out what it actually is and if you
google Houdini you find a lot of stuff
there's like a 3d animation software
that's used wide across the internet you
get to a sporting goods store where you
can buy running shoes and stuff you're
actually on the first page you find a
chair buy some some some company and of
course you find that guy that's really
into chains called Harry Houdini who you
probably know was a magician and well
that's actually the best reference you
will get to the Houdini CSS thing that I
will be talking about because if you
look in the into what it actually is it
is an effort by the we w3c and first
explanation on the wiki page is the
objective of the CSS tag Houdini task
force CSS Houdini is jointly developed
features that explain the magic of
styling and layout on the web so just a
little bit general if you look a little
bit deeper you will find another
explanation by Mozilla which says CSS
Houdini is a w3c effort to define
lower-level CSS api's for authors to
understand recreate and extend
high-level CSS authoring features so
what we actually have here is something
where we can actually get into the inner
workings of CSS and work with that so
where is the use case for that if you
think about it if new CSS features are
coming
and you read about them you're like oh
yeah that sounds really interesting and
I really want to use that and then you
figure out what I go to can I use I look
at at what browser support my CSS
feature and I figured well
chrome is supporting it and nothing else
and then I wait for two years and then I
get to use actually my CSS feature so
this sucks we all know this sucks so
what can we do if we have this problem
in JavaScript what we do is we pull it
in polyfill it so we figure a way out to
go with our existing technologies and go
around to stuff we don't have and build
it in some other way
the problem for CSS is if you look at
what X's we have in the technologies we
have especially in JavaScript yes we can
work with the Dom obviously and we have
a little bit of access to the CSS object
model but not really nice access it's
hard to understand how to work with it
and it doesn't really support much and
all the other tasks that are happening
if we are rendering stuff in the browser
with CSS where we parse the CSS we go
through the Cascade we go through the
layouting we go to the paint process of
the browser we composite all that we
have no access to there's no possibility
good to go into that and this is exactly
where Houdini is coming in didn't - w3c
and pretty much all the big browser
vendors coming together and they try to
define different api's and in Houdini
dare api's for the paint layer of the
process of rendering CSS you can go to
properties and values they want to get
you into the actual OCS CSS object model
there's a way to access the layout
process the parser something for the
animation worklet some
for funds and a bunch of other stuff
that's not really punched out yet and
this talk I will mainly work with the
paint API the properties and layout
properties and values API and the typed
object model and that is mainly because
Houdini is really new and like the
support for adeney is very small as you
can see here the part of the API doesn't
even have a spec the font metrics API
doesn't even have a spec animation
worklet it's just a proposal now it has
a first working draft and as you know
like those those kind of things tend to
change a lot and therefore you can see
not many browsers actually are
implementing any of this yet but since
chrome 65 we got a bunch of stuff that's
actually on the live chrome and that is
the paint API and the type object model
and as well as some other stuff that we
have in canary and I think that's pretty
nice so let's actually look into how we
can use Houdini so what we actually have
to use Houdini is we are using
JavaScript to actually define what
should happen in a certain step what we
actually using here is the paint API and
what we are doing is we are creating a
worklet javascript worklet is something
a little bit like a web worker but
smaller and not that heavy weight
because if you look into the into the
spec of a web worker you will read that
it's not supposed to run a lot of times
and it's very heavy and that's why
worklets were created so this stuff can
actually be used on every paint that is
happening in the browser for the thing
that you are actually styling so as you
can see
it's pretty much just a Java JavaScript
class that I'm creating here in this
JavaScript class we have a actually this
this paint method that will get a
context geometry and some props and
maybe if you're familiar with canvas we
will already see that it looks a little
bit like that so the paint API this
paint method is actually a subset of the
canvas it's pretty much more or less
it's the same only that it has no Dom it
has no text possibility possibilities to
work with text because we're only
working with graphics and that thing and
there's no possibility to access image
data and stuff like that so it's just
like boiled down to the essentials to
work with stuff like backgrounds and
borders and other similar things so what
I'm actually doing here is I'm creating
a paintwork plate that's just rendering
bars into a some some object in HTML so
it's just gonna be a little bit like
when you looking at audio files and
they're dispensing bars and just some
bars next to each other with you can see
it's just they're getting just a random
height up here should have mirrored my
monitor so yeah it's just like random
height every time the paint is called
and then what you have to do is just you
register there paint with your class and
give it a name which is dancing Boris so
next up what I will do is I go to the
HTML and some it's just some small HTML
file it's not really containing much
except for this little script file you
can do it in an Excel
but it's easier to do it here it's easy
to understand and what I do is I call
CSS the paint worklet and on this I add
the module worklet J's which is just my
worklet that I just showed you and
everything else I do is I add a text
area where the class are Dini and
another one which is sibling which is
not that important yet
and now the CSS part is coming up and
all I have to do in CSS is actually sexy
just go to a background image or you
could actually do it with a mask or with
a border and I had this paint method and
at the dancing bars name that I have
written in here so this this thing was
registered on the paint method and now I
can call it in here in my CSS and what
this will turn out to is all right so
this is what actually is getting
rendered it's just the text area it gets
random bars but as you can see if I
change the size of my text area every
time a render is called it changes
because I have random random Heights for
the bars and I just set the width of the
bars correlating to the width of my my
containing object so as you can see it's
always when I'm rendering if I go to my
text area and change let's say the color
of this of this it will not change
because this is not calling a paint only
if I change something like the margin it
will actually change because the paint
is called so you can see really nicely
that it's just happening on paint and
nowhere else so
but now this is kind of encapsulated you
can't do much about it except for like
do some bars and if you look here the
color is hard-coded into it and I just
don't want to do that so what I can
actually use is CSS variables or custom
properties and those custom properties I
can use in my CSS to send some data to
my paintwork let what I have to do for
that is actually I've got it here so I
don't have to write it I go up here so
what I have to do is actually I get the
input properties and I return something
some variable that I call bar color and
now Houdini
will be smart enough to actually get
variables from the baccarat and put it
into props because I put it into into
properties and now I can actually just
use it by calling props get with the
name of the proper I want to call so now
I'm calling bar colors another thing we
have to do so
so Houdini is able to understand this is
actually add a little bit of registry
register paint in here it has to be
registered on the CSS so it can be read
out but the nice thing about this this
is actually typed so you can see the
name is bar color I'm defining that the
sin taxes colors work which gives me
some nice nice possibilities and I can
actually give it an initial value that
will be taken if I don't define this
property on my
CSS so as soon as I've done that I can
just go in here alright so next what I
will do is actually just go in here and
define this color that I defined which
is part color and give it some some
color and this should already change the
color of the thing yes as you can see
it's now tomato and what you can do with
this is actually you can do whatever you
normally do with your CSS and so you can
actually animate that thing so if I add
this keyframe animation which just
rotates the bar color and so if I had
this color rotation animation I give it
two seconds of animation I give it some
steps so it doesn't like go crazy on me
because it's going to often and I run it
all the time you would see that actually
nothing happens what did I do wrong
oh yeah I said it to you I think
I don't know what oh yeah thank you
no anyway yes as you can see so I can
actually use all the capabilities of CSS
like animations to actually work with
this and make it better all right yeah
so far for that so back to the
presentation let's do some real magic
this was just a demo about what you
could do which is just make some bars
dance around which is not really useful
but what if we want to take a tomato and
turn it into a badass or better said
what if we want to make a gradient that
goes from tomato to badass and even
better what if we want to make it a
conical gradient and CSS has a conical
gradient feature but the conical
gradient feature as you can see is not
supported very nicely so now you saw
Houdini is not supported that nicely
there but imagine Houdini would be
supported like fully on all browsers now
we sit here and we see our conical
gradients and we can't use it because
it's not supported anywhere it's behind
a black and chrome and nowhere else so
what would we do we go back to our demos
and here so we just created like a
circle in our CSS and we give it a conic
gradient just so you can see how it
works in the real CSS I got to flag
enabled and in my Chrome Canary so it
shouldn't be a problem
we want to go from tomato to obviously
and yeah so I'm just rendering this here
in a conic class and if I go to my
browser we can see yeah there we have it
that's the standard CSS way that we
would go but as you saw it's not
supported anywhere so next up we want to
go for for the Houdini way and the
Houdini way would be actually to go to
JavaScript and at a paint were clad with
our worklet in it and some properties
which will be gradient started gradient
stuff they are colors they I just
defaulted to white and black so we have
something here and yeah we just you said
it's a little bit complicated I stole
some canonical gradient stuff from the
internet and I tweaked it a little bit
but mainly what we are doing is we
reduce our connect gradient class class
we get our properties into it
we start our paint and then we register
that paint as conic gradient what's
happening here is just pretty much I'm
taking the colors as RGB values and I
read them out I figure out what the
values are and I just transition them
from one to another because I didn't
figure out a better way to do it and
it's just for the sake of like seeing
how a gradient from one value to the
other would work I think there are
better ways are just this morning I saw
today some implementation
connect gradient that is using Houdini
in some kind of way but it actually is
broken right now so it's not working in
the canary with all this stuff enabled
so I'm not sure but the link to it still
is in the presentation and you will get
it later
so yeah I reduced it that I added the
properties in the HTML I added my
worklet and now in the CSS I will just
go here I will take it typing and then
you see I just added my start and stop
values for my gradient I have to use RGB
because my polyfill is not that good but
in later versions you probably can put
in like the word tomato and hex code for
the color and it will work and then I
just paint my conic gradient and as soon
as I save this you would see you nothing
changed this is good because actually
now if I inspect this you will see down
here in the developer tools that now I'm
using background pain conic gradient
instead of the old or the they actually
conic gradient method that would be used
in CSS otherwise so what we actually did
is we just polyfill that feature it's a
small subset of it and it's just like a
proof of concept but it's working and we
can use it and this is what polyfills in
CSS could look like as soon as Houdini
is usable across all browsers and you
can see it it's not too difficult it's
not too much code in the in the
JavaScript as you can imagine all of
this is kind of similar to the canvas or
on a canvas experiment experiments that
you find a good part of them could
probably be usable in there and what I
actually saw is that there are there are
efforts to actually put those properties
that I'm now defining as custom
properties and CSS actually put them
into the paint method so I could just
put them in here but right now it's not
working or at least I didn't find a way
to make it work but that's something
that could happen actually and the good
thing about this is actually that if I
put the custom properties in here and
[Music]
duplicate that and change the properties
around in this context they are scoped
so you can actually make it work a lot
like in actual function only thing you
have to do is not write the properties
that you need into your method but
rather next to it okay so much for the
demos I'm pretty much done this actually
just some helpful links yes
it's very small you figure it out when
you get the presentation
there's the CSS Houdini working group
wiki which is really nice where they're
just showing of what they're working on
there's a lot of stuff that's actually
not Specht out and they're just thinking
about coding in there because so there's
a lot happening and it's really
interesting to look at there's a really
nice article by Smashing Magazine which
is actually already 2 years old where I
heard about it the first time we're just
laying out what you could do with
Houdini and what it's useful for then
there is a really nice article by coda
block which shows
how to use the paint API and this page
were actually a lot of experiments and
stuff are shown with Houdini and with
some like Houdini polyfills so you can
use them more features than actually are
supported in the browser and you can try
out what to Dean you would be helpful to
do with so I really recommend looking at
all this stuff
and keeping an eye on or Deenie because
it will change a lot of things it could
become dangerous but you never know in
the internet what people use this stuff
for but I think it's a nice thing to be
able to polyfill CSS and don't wait for
two years to actually get it so thank
you
[Applause]